欢迎收看赵华
我是赵华
我是艾伦
我们可以想一下
这个礼拜有什么
下个礼拜有什么
下礼拜有放假
那这个礼拜有什么
这礼拜要愿意决策
好
这个礼拜其实有蛮多压力的关卡
可是下个礼拜
有蛮多开心的事情
是的
除了放假 除了中秋节
下礼拜还有台积电的技术论坛
原来是讲这个
而且这礼拜的变音过了之后
下礼拜我们不就是展开一个新局的感觉吗
就放完假回来展开新局
加油
当然很多人也会讨论说
要不要看是不是中秋节后
会有所谓的光辉十月
但也许像今天的盘面
就隐隐透露出大家快要受不了了
有点弱动凑强
是
对啊 陈嘉良原本4000多亿嘛
突然放了1000多亿出来
因为今天早上一开盘
跟昨天一样
要平盘附近震荡
但昨天是尾盘拉肚子
就感受很烂
就今天是盘中就上去了
没错 其实今天尾盘要拉一点肚子
小小的
所以今天是不是有很多中小型股觉得
我不管你晚上怎样
我就是要涨呢
那这样的态势该怎么看
是不是真的不害怕
还有下个礼拜
我们也讲了中秋节的廉价
大家又可以放松一下了
还有台一天的技术论坛
一定会讲很多细光子的好消息
是的
所以我们今天就来帮大家解读一下
这个升息到底是怎么样
我们先来看一下
就是先不讲升息
这个殖利率跟油价都已经先上去了
这些就是跟升息相关的
感觉上现在你殖利率再高
油价再高
怎样我就是升息
对
而且我们现在死猪不怕开水烫
没错就来一起烂
變成這樣是不是
對 因為川普也說
100%支持連準會
他們自己的決定
所以對 他是這樣講的
以前如果是那個誰
那個鮑娥
對 就說什麼爛主席這樣
叫你下台這樣
現在這個人自己推起來了
就是100%支持
不過我們先看一下
不只是30年期
我們10年期
昨天還來講說
有創一個新稿
這一次一樣
昨天晚上繼續衝到了
2007年以來的新稿也就是說目前看起來整個殖利率應該都還是非常在反映就是目前不太樂觀的狀態譬如說偷膨的問題沒錯
然後另外一個則是
不只是單純的殖利率問題
目前油價也遇到了一些問題
沙國油管
對 有被預期
恐過大規模停擺六週
好 那這個是以供給面來的關係
然後就帶動了不然這個原油
還有這個習德州原油
持續的維持在高檔
那這個對於整個科技國來講
它就會是一個壓力
因為對於這種高本益比來講
都會是比較不舒服的狀態
這也是為什麼昨天
其實美國股市還是相對偏弱
對 好 那
沒有 我只是想到說
像那時候關稅前
我們也知道有關稅的事情
所以股市確實也在壓力鍋中
可是沒有想到
關稅真的把大家嚇壞
所以我剛剛只是突然想到說
雖然感覺上
我们现在叫死猪不怕开水烫
但会不会真的很烫
可能还是会熟啦
所以我们后期要持续注意一下
不只是利率决策
当然我们现在短线观察
重点就是利率决策
但其实后面还是要面临的
就是石油价格
持续的往100前高去做卖进
这个整个还是比较辛苦一点点
那我们就先看今晚的状态会是怎么样
那当然讲完之后
我们还是要跟大家讲
其实我们台湾目前看起来
还是相对产业非常强劲的
对啊我们又继续有单位
国发会
把我们的GDP成长率
再往上靠拢
原本11耶
现在来到12了
对啊
是的 好
那目前来说
当然这个看得出来
六七八月
这个是各个地方的
公布的成长率
那目前看起来呢
11不是是最高的
主计总处说11嘛
对 然后国发会有喊到12
对
那不过呢通膨
它也是相对喊比较高一点
我们台湾央行
可能好像也要升息
是 可能可能
禮拜五
就应该知道了
不行吧
现在大家房贷族
还有那些职押股票的
好辛苦啊
对
OK这个也是我们要注意一下
我们台湾确实也有轻微通膨的问题
好那再来看到了就是
这个台积电OIP论坛
9月23
在美国矽谷要登场了
那里面观察了几个重点
有先进日程类
先进封装类
还有矽光子
没错
所以这一些题材
我觉得像今天的矽光子
有重新发酵的意思
有
對 先進的封裝
其實一直都還不錯
先進製程我們就看一下後面的
其實創意已經在創新高了所以後面再看一下有沒有機會繼續去墊高這個我覺得是一個對於半導體來講或者說對於台灣硬體供應鏈來講的
一個信心
現在有利空
利空準備要出境了
所以要有利多
利多要來看有沒有機會
讓整個成交量也一起放大
另外一個就是META有擴大資源晶片的佈局
台積電9月已經交貨了
所以目前看起來都應該是
陸續還是有一些樂觀的新聞出來
所以我們就觀察一下
這個聯準會講完
有沒有辦法放量
放量要向上放量
那這行情就會起來了
好 行情起來的話
我想主要的族群都很清楚
半導體的先進封裝 先進製程
西光子 自研晶片
其實都是圍繞在台灣最強項
就是所謂的半導體上面了
是的 所以我們希望半導體要撐住
因為最近的那個
安詞這件事情
確實還是可能有些因應的
安詞不過
大哥是仁勋
他有投Enthorpic
他有投OpenAI
我都给你们钱了
不要在那边这只叫嘛
所以他有说
我们不需要安全监管法规
我们会在安全的前提下创新的
没错
然后同时有证实
已经美国在太空部署武器了
不是怎么现在战场跑到太空
它可以从上面射下来
我还以为是怎么样
跟外星人打吗
这应该会输吧
其实就越来越像电影情节
你看我们的Anthropy
就是类似那个
也是电影的情节嘛
然后这个打卫星人
也是电影的情节
駭客任务
对
所以目前看起来其实
如果是以一个局外人的角度来看
其实我觉得蛮酷的
局外人
对
就是蛮酷的嘛
你看真的电影的事情是在发生的
以单纯一个人类的角度来讲
AI大脑要来了
是的
但是如果我们以这种
可能我们是比较有在观察这些东西来讲
其实听起来蛮恐怖的
是啦 连太空可能都部署武器
针对针对
一下人类要被统治
一下可能随时都会有人对你射飞弹
然后听起来就比较恐怖一点
那太空武器当然还是有概念股的
包含了就是台积电 声达克 文帽
莱德光还有华通 雅光跟耀灯
今天是有反应的
今天蛮强的
今天有反应 开玩笑
像这个之前都是
那一阵子低微卫星红红的时候
这个没有的一个上涨的强势的个股
莱德光电跟耀灯
嗯 沒錯 好
這個是大家可以去
把它列入自選的
如果對TIC微信有興趣的
可以往這方向去做觀察那再來我們看到就是台灣股市台灣股市呢我們直接先看量量能這幾天都是呈現一個明確的萎縮狀態所以萎縮在幹嘛萎縮就要等放量
放量才有方向
因為無量就無價
那我們之前說過
10日均跟20日均全部都跌破
那我們後續觀察的重點就是
本週一的低點
至少到今天都有做防守
可是防守過程
我們今天盤中漲500點
可是尾盤只有300點
因為又碰到5日均線
就稍微有一些壓力了
不過都還可以接受
只要前低没有破
事件性的一个不确定性结束
行情如果能够垫高
站为全部均线
这边应该就迎来一个
短线反弹的契机
那如果多方要重启
这个前高就要做突破
同时这个高点做突破
基本上就是挑战历史新高
因为趁几百点
对 所以大盘我们看一下
明天跟后天
能不能来一个
比较激情的表现
那贵买就比较单纯
它就是区间震荡
即便今天它的涨势
是比较强的
而且它没有杀尾盘
然后它涨了2.7%
也比上市来得多
所以今天体感其实很舒服的
因为上柜很强嘛
对
那可是呢
大家还是记得
就也不用太兴奋啦
因为就区间整理啦
所以我们后面
当然这边一定还有空间
那上去的时候这种高点
就要收盘价做突破
这个地方只要做突破
这边呢就是一个
新的行情的产生
那成交量呢
如果能够放大到2000亿以上
会更漂亮
所以上市要守前低
上柜再区间整理
都等一个前高的突破
去做一個新型態的產生
那就是要等事件性了
等明天大家兩百萬放出來
沒錯
那因為那個漢測結束了嘛
我聽說是有幾千億
八千六百億
是的
這個是一天台灣股市的成交量
我今天都聽到的都是背報
背報沒有抽到
還是要上班
抽到也不用上班
會去抽的都已經是有錢人了吧
對啊
平白無故225萬放在那裡
沒錯
那我們來看一下聯電
聯電怎麼了
聯電很棒
聯電這一波
聯電很棒是不是
對 你看這一波是盤整
那盤整拉上去之後
這個是漲停板
可以發現我們剛剛台灣股市
是這樣向下玩
對 聯電是 橫的
對 守住了一個平台
所以目前來說
聯電最近的型態
其實都相對比較強勁一點
蓄勢待發
對 跌的時候也跌比較少
那漲的時候它也是有份
那量價這邊比較可惜
這四天都是萎縮的
所以一樣等一個突破
那突破之後
這基本上就是先補缺口
再看前高
好
對 這個是連電
平台突破
再來是看到我們的
日月光
大平台
沒錯 慢慢的大平台
好 就是長這樣
好 結束了
沒有啦開玩笑
就是這個高點還是要
其實這邊已經有做突破
但後面行情整個不好
又被整個帶下來
它這裡創反彈高
那隔天直接跌6%很過分
所以日月光的股性
目前真的是比較不舒服一點點
但是我們等一下來賓會提到
相關的一些題材面
大風測時代要來了
是的 所以日月光
成長要加速了
沒錯 如果短線上來講
這邊就可能要有些耐心
等形態上的好轉
但是它這邊就很抗跌
因為雖然抗漲
但也相對抗跌
那就看后续行情能不能
做一个明确的多方债勤
然后再去创高
然后再去挑战思维术
是 那对FORTA有信心
因为资本支柱都在今年
做一些摊提折旧了
明年就是要等营收灌进来
是 所以如果对于长线
有点耐心的热热光是可以看的
那再来我们刚提到了
就是FOMC会议纪要
原来你是华先生
没有 我是分析华先生的
好 因为你竟然
这个大家可以赶快加一下
艾伦说的Lite
他会这个凌晨不睡觉
看华许讲什么
帮大家来解读
到底FOMC会议
这个东西有好几个事情要拆解
不是叫做
9月升息就事情结束了
到底未来10月12月
明年年中之前
会不会持续升息
它跟台股的排面
真的叫息息相关
是关注通膨
还是关注AI的发展
这个也跟后世息息相关
所以这份报告还蛮重要的
希望艾伦认真写
好 我认为
他就用力加起來
等著他明天發送這份報告喔
那廣告回來剛剛特別提到
下禮拜值得期待
Tayden的技術論壇
要講的事情絕對就是CPU
好 來吧
光通訊吸引黃金時代
1.6T 接放起飛
今天真的是光通訊蠻熱的
也有很多人講說
發現自己焊測沒抽到
就趕快回來買一下雍智
買一下CPU
因為是同一個族群這樣
好 那確實啦
今天的CPU相關的
或者檢測相關的
其實真的還蠻強勢的
對 那我們就來看一下
最近依舊有一些新的題材
在做一個延招
像高盛有大升800G
跟光模組的需求
2027年會上修39%出貨
對 所以目前看起來
不只是需求很大甚至是出貨也開始順利了而且現在大家都酷2027就明年是的其實就是在看明年了因為也要準備Q4了那我覺得這個都是好事800G目前來說
是大型資料中心的主流規格
那1.6T會開始放量
3.2T則是
2027年會開始採用
所以這個光傳輸的速度
越來越大管
然後這個速度越來越快
我覺得這個都是正向的發展
另外一個則是中國這邊的
它有一個光博會
1.6T已經成為主流了
從光引擎 光晶片
还有解调器跟光纤材料测试设备
都已经迎来一个新产品的迭代
所以目前来说整个有几个特色
第一个800G依旧是主力
那1.6T准备要量产
3.2T跟6.4T
跟以NPO还有CPO的样机验证为主
这里是主力
这是明年的主力
这个是未来的主力
而且有讲到一个NPO
它就比较有机会在2027年放量
而且大家有在讨论
美中虽然在科技战
但似乎并没有要去阻止
中国的CPU
是喔 看起来是这样
都在讲晶片
可是却没有去讲CPU这一块
可见的需求应该是非常大
对 而且它可能
它也只是传输用
它不是头脑
它可能现头脑
但是中间的这些材料
或者是过程
就不会这么大的限制
好 这个是CPU
近期相关的一些利多
那我们就来看一下
台湾股市的相关
光通讯的个股
好 都回档过了
今天符合形态转好吗
有一些些有
尤其現在比較可惜
像聯亞就很可惜
聯亞盤中快漲停板
它3,600跌到2,600嘛
跌1,000多塊
對啊 一下就跌1,000多塊
是很莫名其妙
可是這一波反彈起來
其實它目前還是一個整理的形態
今天啦 因為尤其又很可惜
它原本漲停後面只剩4.8%
對 那其他的像是光盛
我覺得這個都還差一點點
光盛啊 然後還有誰
波若薇也還差一點點
那華新礦也前一陣子跌太重
它出關跌太重了
結果有點落差
剩下我覺得形態都還可以
這個環宇KYA還差一點點
對 其他我覺得都還不錯
我們等一下會一個一個慢慢帶
而且光鏡頭又回來了
是的 連一光真的是很猛
連一光好扯
對 一直往右上角走
台股好像他家開的一樣
對啊
有道理
對啊 連一光很誇張
這明明就是第三名
大力光跌了那麼重
玉京光難得來一個反彈
但是它已經創高再創高了
對 所以我們今天稍微來看一下
對 還跟大家講一下
目前整個年增來講
前幾名都還是非常大的年增所以目前他們基本面是有在逐步轉好的好 那我们来看一下里面其中几位第一位就是全新他其实蛮高姿态
是的 那为什么要讲他呢
因为他高姿态
还是一个横向的震荡
也就是他以盘待跌
你看像我们刚刚讲
可能零化英大概主要二到三家
就全新跟联亚
对 文貌甚至还
近期讨论度比较低一点
对 可是这两家都零化英
但我们刚刚说
那個全新是
聯亞是這樣嘛
就這邊是跌了1000塊
那全新它是在區間震盪
那為什麼你不學回檔過的啊
這麼高檔你不會怕嗎
可是我的想法是它以盤代跌
對就是不肯下車嘛
那不肯下車就是等軍線跟上
等新的一波動能進來
所以我覺得全新在這個位置上
你看這邊是碰月線新高
所以月線要來了
那停頌電也很好抓
就是這個大量這邊
這個低點跟這個低點
如果没有做跌破
其实我觉得就可以
让它在这边横盘震荡
等一个新高
那如果需要节省一些时间的
有创高再来追就好了
所以全新我觉得
现在形态很强
虽然是创新高在高档震荡
好 再来另外一个呢
就是潜顶
潜顶算厉害的了
是的
这一波潜顶算猛的
潜顶呢也是有说
有接到辉达的那个订单
我以前记得潜顶
都是那种50块而已
那个时候跟比价
就是潜顶跟重达
对 然后现在已经是250了
对 它这一波
好这个潜顶我们这个价格修正一下
265耶
没错
50块变265了
是的
从这边算就好
就印象里面百元以下的股票
没错潜顶这一波其实
这一波反弹的趋势
其实是算强劲的
甚至比华信光那些都来得强
对那目前来讲
我们近期可以发现
它股价在这边做一个横盘的震荡
所以我觉得这里只要大量高点
去跟着做突破
这应该前高做突破之后
就是再往前面高点去做买进
所以前景来讲
我觉得这一波
其实形态上也都相对是健康的
我们就找那种相对比较健康的形态
那再来看到另外一个
就是这个重达KY
位阶相对就好像比较低
今天低位阶的其实还蛮多
就拉一个涨停板
对 其实有很多
环宇KY
对
然后其实还有其他都有涨停板
什么瑞森光
瑞森光电有吗
它不是CPU
不好意思
不是这个光电
冬點光電
好的好的 OK
我們來看一下
仲達其實最近也在抽籤今天是最後一天對 那抽籤的過程中今天最後一天就有放量区做进攻了那仲达我觉得这个形态我也蛮喜欢的
虽然它曾经跌破了上升趋势线
这边然后跌破掉
可是呢今天是站上了下降趋势线
然后一口气站回全部均线
然后今天又出一个量
所以在这个状态之下
我觉得至少这里的低点
应该短期内都不会再跌破
那大家就可以去关注一下
如果我进场
听孙姐也抓这里
那看能不能启动一波
创高的新行情
好 它是现真
现真的话通常缴完款之后
就看看是不是
之后不被这个扰乱了
现在只要募资的都会有点压力
是的 所以已经尾声了
那尾声就看有没有机会
来做一个发动
那另外整个营收也还不错
年增100%
单月的营收有跳升了
所以应该是反映
整个高速光通讯的产品
有拉获的
这个是后续大家可以
好好去注意一下的
一个低位阶转强
再来另外一个呢
就是我們的友達
超級便宜
嗯 對
兇啦
好 二十幾塊
是
對 因為他之前是掌輸群創嘛
對
但這一波他的形態
是不是比群創還要強
是的 因為前一陣子
可能上半年在掌群創的時候
講的題材只有群創有
群創就是有CPU
然後也有跟台積電的合作
對 然後又賣廠
對 那下半年呢
友達也在做一樣的事情
友達又有廠可以賣啊
是的 這個
對 他最近也在做
它的资产的减肥
就是整个的状态都在规模变小
因为股价这样可能比较拉
比较明确一点
那相关的整个在半导体展
有秀出了整合RDL封装
光学偶合的技术
里面有相关的CPU
就是低功耗
而且可以量产的
目前来说其实就也切入
台积电相关的供应链
当然有在证实
但坊间已经
没错
把他们撮合了
是的
所以季群创之后呢
反而因为友达这一波
他前面涨比较少
那这里反而是他股性
比较活泼一点点
当然今天群传也不错
涨了4%
不过形态上就有些落差
因为群传可能连季线都还没站上
那我们来看一下友达前一阵子
是来到了盘中的新高
然后也是前一波的高点
所以这边是套牢区
那套牢区就拉了一个上引线
那上引线之后刚好伴随大盘
行情比较正当一点
他就一度回撤到了
我觉得上来不错的位置
就是原本是压力区
这是大量嘛
原本是壓力區
然後呢
站上之後轉為支撐區的地方
所以在今天有拉起來
我覺得都還算健康
那當然五日軍線沒有站上我覺得有點可惜
所以在这边的行情
都还是一个N字形
那接下来这个是新的N字形
所以只要再做一个带量供期
这边行情应该就是要准备去创新高
或者是说先挑战前高
再挑战创新高
这个目前我觉得都值得期待
然后筹码目前有去看了一下
其实是比群创稍微来得健康一点点
对 所以我觉得这边有主力在这边蹲
大家可以不妨去多关注一下
有没有机会再拉一个新的形态
好 而且有党的空单
但我记得是不少的
是
可能也有酝酿看会不会有点嘎空
其实以前面板双火空单真的多
就看他们没有啦
但是拉上来的话
可能也会有嘎空的行情
对
好 所以如果需要今天节目
所有的图卡资料的话
欢迎订阅一下我们
赵华艾伦说的YouTube频道
我们每一集都会把这些图卡
免费放在首页有一个贴文栏
点进去就可以做下载
慢慢的研读
因为等一下我们有两位大来宾
一个要讲产业 一个要讲量价关系
都非常值得听
就是因为现在是一个关键转折点
那我们来期待一下吧
欢迎回来赵花
我跟你说
我跟你讲我们节目超级有诚意的
因为呢
现在不是都在讲成交量低吗
没错
结果我们要增加来宾的人数
嘿嘿
多一点人来喊信心喊话
因为我们两个人讲
可能不够了
所以我们要让大家知道
像现在比较沉浅
或者是有一些关卡卡在这边的时候
往往酝酿的叫做什么呢
什么
黎明前的黑暗将来就会是大展光明
哦 突然好正像
好正能量
好 突然
登轰 做一下效果
我们先来欢迎今天大来宾有两位
第一位呢
久久还很久没有来了
但是每次观众
看到她來都非常開心的
就是統一投顧的總經理
PCB女王賴婉婷
歡迎婉婷
嗨 趙華艾倫
我突然卡住
太久沒來了
好 今天婉婷來
要先幫我們從產業面上
打雞鞋啦
好嘞
因為婉婷前陣子去看了
半導體展
所以對於第四季到明年
今天我們不講PCB
今天反而是要講
看完半導體展之後
你有一個感想就是大封册时代要来临了对我们很需要你的加持因为说实话今年封测股的涨势其实是没有其他的AI股来得多
然后一直在期待业绩
高快成长
那为什么看完半导体展之后
会觉得大封测时代要来临
另外当然是最近
大家比较担心的
AI真的有降速降规的问题吗
好 就是周末的时候
三大巨头
Athropeak开始讲
他的員工就離職
然後就說再不管的話
AI會完蛋
然後他有可能在未來的某一天
殺死全人類
有10%的機率
10%還滿高的
對 然後所以SOPIC就開始講
就呼籲說要放慢發展的速度
好 但是這個是指的是AI的模型
它並不是表示AI的基建
其實模型跟基建是兩件事
而且呢
模型它指的是非常前沿的
就是還在可能沙盒裡面測試的
並不是現在已經開始開賣的模型
那現在開賣的這些大魚人模型
才是會跟基建比較直接的相關
所以我不會認為說
這個時間點AI的基建會放緩
只要AI基建沒有放緩
台灣的賣產值的業績
就會繼續的水漲船高
是
對 所以我覺得這個恐慌有
因為大家搞不清楚
所以需要我們來跟大家說清楚
好 那大家的信心回來了之後
這件事情立空就會結束
然後當然就是因為大家害怕
所以股市包括半導體費半就跌了
然後所以川普跟華人勳
就通上了電話
然後告訴大家說
才不會咧
AI算力本來就是未來的國力
還有新石油
所以怎麼可能會停止
然後所以末日論就是一個騙局
對 所以大佬就跟你講說
不要太擔心
好 一個是美國的BOSS
一個是AI央行BOSS
沒錯
這個Enthropic跟OpenAI
回答的都是大股東而已
所以黃仁勳講話
他們應該要聽一下吧
對 是
對 所以基本上
我們認為不太會停手啦
對 所以大家不用那麼恐慌
可是你這個信心
需要被安撫一下
好 對
但是呢 我們這邊要信心安撫
除了大佬的喊話
其實前一陣子的半導體站
展前轟轟烈烈
就展後大家安安靜靜
但是其實婉婷去看完之後
心裡是激動的
對 我是覺得很棒的
那我覺得
我刚刚在赵海来介绍的时候
我突然想到一个点
就是为什么今年风测股比较弱因为今年是涨价年今年是供需失衡的涨价年对对 那但是今天的发展是它是盖房子它房子现在里面越堆越多越盖越大
但是呢
封册它并没有走向涨价这件事情
它在盖房子
可是它没有
这个房子没有在涨价
所以今年的投资主轴
它跑去了供需失衡的涨价股
导致这种盖房子越盖越大
但是加量不加价的
看起来股价比较弱
可是明年我认为
我自己会认为说
供需失衡这件事情会慢慢淡化
所以涨价的族群
它的光环可能会退掉
它也许不会跌
因为AI还在发展
他们的公司的企业获利还会在增长
可是价格虚动力会不见
好那所以回来
大家就会看规格升级这个议题
好那规格升级这个议题
就是晶片现在因为你
功能要越来越多
你2.5D封装变3.3D封装
3.5D封装
那这个就是有点像之前
就是记忆体跟主晶片放在一起
就COAS
然后未来就是COOP或CPU
你的OE光引擎会进来
然后再共同封装
所以它就会从2.5D往3.5D走
好 然后所以当你要放
越来越多东西的时候
你的房子就要越盖越大
你才住得下这么多的人
好 所以你封装
就叫做盖房子把房子盖起来
封装的厂商订单就会越来越多
好 然后可是今年比较辛苦的
就是我們之前提到
日月光晶圓店
因為它資本支出先投
它要蓋房子
它必須要有產能
它先投了
折舊出來
結果業績還不夠
然後就導致獲利成長性不夠強
那跟這個報價類股PK就輸了
所以封測廠商經營獲利的YY
強度不夠
大家就不愛
可是明年
我已經投完了
我接下來要開始創造收入
創造獲利
所以明年的重點就會再封測
是
對 那我在半導體展看到就是
好多複雜的晶片
然後廠商在告訴你說
我在這裡面扮演什麼樣的角色
那像這個就是日月光展的
這個就是一個CPL的模型
然後這個就是所謂的ESIC或GPU
然後這就是記憶體堆疊
這個就是所謂的2.5D封裝
然後在旁邊這個放的就是OE引擎
然後這樣一大顆
就是一個非常大的晶片
以前晶片只有這樣一顆
現在晶片這麼大顆
對 所以這個就是我當初在講
為什麼載版用量會增加的關鍵
好 然後這個也是
其實就是堆疊式封裝
所以你就會知道說要這樣封裝除了先進製程很強然后再来就是大晶片我封装大晶片对 大晶片架构
所以我把它浓缩叫大封测
哦
好 大封测
对 晶片越来越大
然后封装的需求才能消耗
然后测试时间要变长
所以大封测
然后相关的材料设备股都会收回
好 然后所以我在现场
我也看到也有封测
还有测试的探针卡
还有这个测试底座
所以我們從就是
Pro卡 探針卡
然後到這個測試機座的引威
然後到這個SLT
還有這個
那個Final Test
就是晶片測試
好 這些就是過去我們講
引威 旺系
好 然後跟這個老化測試
就是一樣就是金測
好 這些就是測試設備
然後呢 晶圓測試的部分
主要在COAS
它就會是台積電跟日月光座
然後晶片測試的話
就是那个晶圆电
好 所以日月光晶圆电
然后跟我们刚刚讲的
金测 影威 望系
都会是有关系
跟晶片有关
然后另外就是光的部分
因为光OE引擎要进来
然后所以现在设备厂商
积极的在做这个光晶片的测试
那它总共有四个步骤
然后第二个步骤
跟第三个步骤最难做
所以这个有点卡关
让OE引擎稍微比较慢的原因
可是就是因为卡关
所以它是更重要的
对 所以我这边就帮它整理了一下
今年跟明年的获利
然後就可以看到很明顯的
就是有一些獲利的成長性很強
是
對 然後題材性在這邊
好 然後本益比的部分
其實為什麼今年不漲
因為今年其實出
大家就知道大晶片概念
所以股價漲超多
去年底到今年漲很多
所以PE本來拉太高
但是因為最近休息了
所以反而你現在往時間點
多過了一年之後
你會發現它PE掉下來了
對 然後明後年大風測
獲利成長性夠高
PE又沒有很高的時候
我觉得这个族群
就会是今年底往明年
很好的布局的产业
好 因为像尹为曾经是万元股
没错
结果现在已经掉到6000块了
虽然是高价股
但回档幅度非常深
事实上如果明年能够呼应
它可能有高达这个
70几%的年增率的话
它搞不好又可以
重新回到一个成长的轨道上
哦 是这样看
略光跟晶圆店
就是相对比较牛皮
比较委屈的
对 可是因为PE很低
对
对 所以非常安全
好 所以要成長有成長
要安全有安全
好 那我們就來看一下
日月光真的橫盤真理
金元店也很多人
就是投訴說
到底為什麼
他不是資本
已经创下令年新高
怎么还没有涨这样子
对 因为它
其实去年涨非常多
但是今年就受到
它的资本支出
所以导致折旧增加太多了
可是这些折旧对明年就是好事
因为我的业绩就可以开始
创造收入
是 好
所以这个是安全组
对 就是风色双雄
这个就是活泼组
但是潜力无穷
对 那像今天雍智就涨停
对 因为它就是有
透过风肌肌
然后拿到有机会切进联发科
然后因为联发科
就是大家很關注它Google訂單
所以就會覺得它未來成長性會有機會
然後另外旺席的部分的話
其實大家期待很高
可是因為它最近那個之前的座談會
講第三季的展望講的稍微比較保守
所以股價就相對比較弱
可是9月如果出來優於公司獎
大家就會認為說公司可能是過度保守
那未來的期待還是很高的時候
可能反而股價就會在那個時間點動
好 就是很謝謝婉妮跟我們分享了
看完半導體戰以後
迎接所謂的大風測試代表
謝謝你 好 謝謝
好 歡迎回來趙華
阿倫說
我們趕快來歡迎第二位來賓
剛剛已經講了產業面
是 接下來就要看
所謂的量價關係了
非常重要 雲線沒量
雲線沒量 沒關係
朱老師來就有量
現在來歡迎他
就是我們的朱家弘老師
K線之神
大家好
跟我们太熟了
对 常常碰面
对
因为最近朱老师
有帮盘下了一个注解
好事总是多磨
因为盘好磨
没错 没错
最近盘大家觉得很难做
但是什么事情都有这个
好事多磨
那就后面有好事
所以现在在磨磨你
对 但是不管
我们在这个中间很难做
但是你一定会有收获的
那投资也是一样
我们投资也是有赚有赔
但是你在赚赔的中间
你也会有很多宝贵的信念
然后奠定你日后成功
所以你经过一段磨练
那以后大机会来
那你就是你的
因为大家可能被前一阵子
那种大的波动养坏胃口了
其实股市的盘整是常态
对
所以从盘整中找机会是更重要的
沒錯
主老師最近我們一直在講就是量的問題沒錯因為好的時候有到1兆就1.8兆现在的话五六千亿差这么多
所以量价关系要教我们来看
股价的推背图
其实在股市里面
你如果看懂量价关系
你都知道它后面的变化
但是一般人为什么不太容易分辨
就是你把量价关系
跟趋势分开来了
你只看量
实际上我们看量价关系
要跟趋势结合
你是在看多头空头
还是现在在盘整
盘整里面也会有量
有的时候有量说
有的时候量真
好 像多头趋势
这边有讲多头起涨
量真就一涨
我们大部分都做多
所以如果你是在起涨
也就是我们讲的回后埋上涨
盘整突破
这都是第一根
如果第一根有量的话
那这个我们一般来说
它就容易涨
也叫做攻击量
这个量叫攻击量
多头行进中的话
量争就会续涨
对 那如果一样
它行进的意思就是第二天第三天
第二天第三天连续再放量
那当然它就是继续在攻击
那如果多头遇到高档量争就不好了
那高档我们就讲过三天以上
第三天第四天
这个地方如果继续的放大量的话
那你就要小心了
因为在高档有量
这个容易被人家出货
因为有量说他们没办法出货
但量一大就容易出货
那怎么观察呢
就是如果它有大量
第二天股价不涨了
或者当天
当天放了大量
结果开高走低
股价下跌
那这时候大概出货的
几率就非常高
你要小心
那同样的一样
上涨到高档预压了
预压力的预压
量增也是同样是出货的概念了
因为你预压
本來就是有人在解套
到了這些位置
你就要注意
這個地方可能是出貨
換句話講
第一個我們做多不會買在高檔
也不會買在壓力
可是你手上有多單
這時候你要準備停曆
要停曆
好 最後當然是剛剛講到
這些可能都造成回檔
可是回檔只要量開始縮了
那就代表賣壓減少了
因為多頭回檔
在高檔爆量就是
該出的就出了
或解套的有賣掉了
那你这时候就要看回来
如果回来量缩掉
这个量缩反而好
表示卖压减轻
也没有那个很大的继续在杀你那如果量缩的话碰到支撑了就容易停住了因为我们支撑就是一个对抗下跌
你下跌量少
我支撑够强
我自然就会把它抵住
点住的时候我们就会看到
它会不会又出现
第一个量增上涨
对不对
因为你量缩
然后我把你撑住
你再出来一个量增的上涨
那它又開始攻下面一波
好 一個循環
這在多頭裡面
大概你的位置都有了
多頭上漲 高檔 預壓 回檔
預支撐
大概你把這些量放上去
你做多大概可以研判
那在空頭裡面就不一樣
空頭裡面各位就不要看錯了
比如說空頭起跌
就低跟下跌
低跟下跌如果有大量
那就不但會跌還容易急跌
可能连续就煞下去了
所以在空头的起跌这地方
是我们做空
那做空有量就变好了
它会大跌
所以就可以继续空
那行径如果量缩
大家容易误会
这跟刚才不一样
刚才说下跌量缩好
对不对
这边讲的
可是空头下跌量缩
还会继续跌
因为各位要有一个观念
我空头下跌是不是
要涨的话要有人来买
要有人接
對 那如果你是量縮
表示你不要亂接
很多人都看價錢去接股票
跌三天了 我在摸底
那結果它沒有量
我們一般閃會去摸
你摸不出來的
一定要有別人來大量
所以量縮會續跌
那空投低檔就是跌了兩三天
也就是這個的相反
跌了兩三天
量放大了
它反而容易止住
就是有点底部放大量
对底部放量
然后有人来买了
这个时候容易反弹
容易反弹我们要确认
那就是第二天
我如果底部放量
第二天不跌了
或者下引线或者变
这个地方大概就容易反弹
那容易反弹对我们来讲
因为我们做多
空头你不能做多
反弹不能做多
所以这是给你空单要回补的
如果你是做空单
在低档也看到大量
那你就準備要回補了
要回補了
那如果你下跌遇到了支撐空頭 我們現在都在講空頭不是多頭遇到支撐空頭如果遇到支撐比如說你跌跌跌到半年線那這個地方如果出現有量大
它一樣也容易反彈
這個地方有支撐
就有支撐的力量出現
那另外空投上漲
那叫反彈
所以這個都要搞得
空投反彈如果量縮
它就容易結束了
也就是說我們反彈無量
反彈無力
反贪物量就准备做空
准备 也许它谈不动
明天就跌了
那明天一跌又回来这里了
又变起跌了
我们多空都有讲
对 所以多空不但有讲
而且多空的每个位置
你都可以去配合再看一下
你今天看到的大量
是多头的这里了
还是空头的这里
那我相信你对这个量
就能够分析了
那还有一个盘整
大家比较忽略盘整
那盤整裡面有兩種情形
在多頭的盤整
如果這個多頭要攻的話
大概量都會縮
在盤整裡面不太會有量
那在什麼時候才有量
就是盤整的突破
也就是我們多頭的起漲
那盤整的突破
那這個時候就會有量
那另外一個就是盤整放量
在多頭也會盤整裡面放量
那這要小心 要看位置
如果你這個盤整在第三波
陌生段
那有可能會做頭
所以不能跌破
如果盤整放量的跌破
那个量就是阻力出货
就阻力出货
那空头如果是跌到低档了
空头一直跌跌到低档
那也在盤整
这个地方如果放量的话
那就是我们刚刚讲
空头放量就会反弹
那这个地方放量盤整
如果是突破它就转多了
那这个量就叫
我们就叫做进货量
阻力在这边进货
所以你如果是盤整
也是看多頭的盤整
還是空頭的盤整
還是多頭底部的盤整
還是空頭底部的盤整
還是多頭高檔的盤整
你加上量價
最後看它是突破還是跌破
你大概也知道
這個成交量代表什麼意思
是 我們現在的台股位置
算是多頭高檔的盤整嗎
對 因為現在跌破前提
所以是盤整
那現在盤整量輸
對 好不好
原來是好事
我們講了那麼大一篇
現在是好事
對啊
所以我們現在大凡趨勢感的
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕